welcome welcome to another fed Day fomc
Day edition of Market takes I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me and I appreciate
that thank you so much I am Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal uh
this is Market takes we are diving into
today's fomc press conference the
statement uh the decision uh all that
we're gonna break down what all of it
means and explain why it matters today's
meeting I think was a little bit more
subdued a little bit you know you didn't
have a lot of the big fireworks that
we've come to expect from fed day but
nonetheless there is some very important
context that we are going to get into
right here on Market takes we're going
to talk about of course the Fed rate
decision and how that aligned with
expectations we're going to talk through
what's going on the markets how markets
reacted across stocks bonds currencies
uh Commodities all that good stuff and
of course we're gonna talk about the
environment coming into the meeting and
how today's meeting and press conference
and all that may have shifted things
going forward and then of course we will
talk about what comes next because you
know even though it's backward looking
data we are always looking forward
anyway silicon let's get to it the fed
this the FED decision today the fomc
raised rates by 25 basis points this was
widely expected widely priced in not
surprising anybody the FED raising rates
from 4.75 to 5 to 5 to 5.25 effectively
5.1 percent want to put a chart up here
on your screen so you can just look for
yourself and see kind of the environment
that we have right now all the way on
your right you see how high the rates
have gotten we are back above five
percent that is the highest the rates
have been since uh September of 2007 so
almost 16 full years since we've had
rates this high and you see what
happened after rates were that high they
came back down pretty quick we had a
recession as you see with their shaded
in
um that is not necessarily uh indicative
of what will happen now past results are
not indicative of future results but uh
we shall see it's definitely going to be
interesting we are interesting we are
entering the interesting times now the
times where things get a little bit
harder a little more difficult for the
FED for Fed chair Jerome Powell so that
charge is kind of illustrating where we
are in terms of the Fed rate and how
that compares with recent history at
least over the past 20 years
um a big thing that I think was
interesting from this report my biggest
takeaway in terms of the statement was
the change that instead of saying
there's some additional firming already
that that could be done the statement
now says we are the FED is determining
the the extent to which some additional
policy firming may be appropriate uh RSM
Chief Economist Joe Bruce Willis said it
was they were quote opening the door to
a strategic pause at the June meeting
basically that was markets takeaway the
FED said that they were going to kind of
reassess reevaluate they were going to
hike today but at the press conference
even Fed chair Jerome Powell said the
changes in the statement were
intentional they made those changes to
say look it's time we kind of step back
we've been raising rates every meeting
10 straight meetings they've increased
rates including raising 75 basis points
three times the normal Pace at four
meetings earlier this year so some big
changes were made and now we're entering
a new phase of this rate hiking cycle
and that's what I think you're seeing
the market respond to right now coming
into this meeting today
um things have been pretty
straightforward and easy right now it's
not necessarily easy to raise rates
because of course markets want low rates
but with inflation being high it got up
to as high as nine percent in June of
course the FED has to raise rates it's
pretty simple inflation goes up the FED
has to respond by raising rates they put
it off in 2021 saying transitory
transitory we think it's going to go go
away on its own when that didn't happen
it became clear they had to raise rates
they did that now we're entering the
phase where it's not going to be so easy
anymore you had high inflation low
unemployment well in that case you raise
rates it's very simple and the
unemployment rate didn't pick up very
much as they've been raising rates what
you were starting to see in the data and
we'll get more into this in just a
second is the unemployment data started
moving the opposite direction you're
saying job losses start to pick up
you're seeing inflation start to come
down and now the FED really has to make
a hard choice or start making some hard
choices in the next few months so the
Fed was really setting the table for
that uh come coming into today now we
had seen an environment where stocks had
been rising you saw the S P 500 up
around seven percent year-to-date uh it
had been up almost it had reached a
pretty high point recently NASDAQ up
about 15 hitting its highest since
September 12 2022 on Friday really
almost all of this growth happened in
January but we have seen stocks picking
up bond yields on the other side going
down that free Layman's out there means
an easing of financial conditions when
they say Financial conditions easing
that's what they mean making it easier
for companies to issue stock because
stock prices are high or to borrow money
because bond yields are low that makes
it cheaper to borrow that's what we're
seeing right now out there in the
economy for big companies and when
you're starting to move into an
environment where things could be a
little tighter a little more uncertain
as we go forward so want to throw up
another thing on your screen right here
and this is the fed's balance sheet now
what you've seen over the past few years
is you see the balance sheet just pick
up and hit these extreme levels where
are passing 5 trillion 6 trillion seven
trillion eight trillion getting almost
to nine trillion dollars and then we had
what was known as QT sort of start to
begin late last year and then when this
banking crisis happened you see that
pickup there right at the end and that
was the FED injecting of the 300 billion
dollars into the system into the banking
system to try to stem these outflows and
and worries in the banking sector about
collapsing and the you know some
contagion in terms of banks a lot of
loans made to Big Banks a lot of buying
up of Bad Assets but now we're seeing
that reverse again and you're seeing the
line starting to point down you're
seeing the beginning of QT again AKA
quantitative tightening that just
illustrates the way the fed's balance
sheet has moved long term and we are
entering a phase now where the FED
doesn't have the wind at its back
anymore you know instead of putting that
injecting injecting money into the
financial system as they had been doing
getting that balance sheet all the way
up there to near nine trillion dollars
we are I in theory at least going going
to be moving down where they're taking
money out of the financial system while
holding rates high and that is going to
weigh on the economy so like I said the
easy part is over now we're moving into
the harder part I want to put one more
thing up here on your screen and it's
just some more economic data this is the
comparison of job openings versus
unemployed people in the U.S and Fed
chair Jerome Powell has mentioned this a
number of times he said just today
during his press conference there's
still 1.6 unemployed people or 1.6 job
openings for every unemployed person so
even if we uh even if we found jobs for
every single person counted as
unemployed in the country there would
still be millions of job openings left
over to be unfilled keep in mind whether
someone is unemployed or not does not
determine whether they are unemployed
that doesn't make any sense here's what
I mean by that someone could be out of a
job but if they're not actively looking
for a job if they are not telling the
Bureau of Labor Statistics I am out here
looking for a job and I just can't find
one if they're not checking in with some
sort of government agency saying I'm
looking for a job they're not unemployed
they are out of the labor force and what
we have seen is a significant increase
in the number of people out of the labor
force just not being counted a lot of
those people working age people between
25 and 55 so-called prime age workers
they are not unemployed they're just out
of the labor force if they're not
looking for a job so the number of
unemployed people has been has been
declining pretty significantly over the
past 20 years and we saw that speed up
after covet so again you're seeing the
number of job openings decline but
there's still a lot of job openings out
there a lot of work looking or a lot of
people looking for workers a lot of work
to be done this chart illustrating that
Trend but you're seeing a decline in the
number of job openings and you're seeing
that number of unemployed people stay
pretty steady because while some people
are coming back into labor force other
people are getting laid off and that's
why we see kind of that that line not
really moving so now let's take a look
at the market right now and let's take a
look at what we're seeing from stock
prices now look we've got this overview
I'm checking out Commodities I want to
take you back to the overview and let's
look at the stock market this is the Dow
you're seeing the Dow down about 0.8
percent right now compare that to the
NASDAQ down about half as much but you
see the same Trend right whether you're
looking at the Dow the S P 500 or the or
the the Nasdaq all three this is the Dow
and you see right around two o'clock
when the FED releases a statement the
market picks up and then you see the the
statement come on the press conference
starts about 2 30 and then you see
things just really start to unravel and
the sales just pick up and people are
selling out of those stocks I think this
is just a little bit of a buy the rumor
sell the news folks expected this
statement to be dovish folks expected
the FED to raise rates by 25 basis
points and when I say dovish what I mean
is the Fed saying okay we think things
are going to be easier we are leaning
towards keeping rates lower or pushing
rates lower in the future the market has
priced in that the FED is going to start
cutting rates later on today and what
we're seeing right now I think
illustrates the expectations from
markets and from investors that the FED
is going to start moving away from
raising rates moving towards cutting
rates we see that with fed fund Futures
prices as we look out across the market
and we're seeing with commodity I think
the big moves that we've seen over the
past couple days oil prices are down
about 10 percent over the last couple
days you're seeing that and that was why
we started off with with commodities
prices oiled down big natural gas down
big those Commodities which are very
sensitive to the economy are starting to
move lower in a drastic and significant
way we aren't seeing it in stock prices
yet we've seen it in Bonds in the bond
market over the past couple weeks but we
aren't seeing stocks just yet so
definitely something to keep your eye on
I think what we're seeing right now in
Commodities is important and definitely
worth watching so let's talk about the
press conference really quick because
that was something I think that you know
there weren't a lot of fireworks as I
said earlier there wasn't any big
blowout Bombshells from Fed chair Jerome
Powell he really just kind of laid it
out we think now is the time to pause
we're going to be data dependent meaning
that depending on what happens with the
data we will act what we can raise rates
we can cut rates we can keep rates where
they are but I think right now the bias
for the FED based on what we heard from
the chairman and what we read in that
statement uh that came out around two
o'clock is that the fed's bias is to
hold Pat not raise rates not cut them
but just hold them here at this very
high level the market does not agree the
market thinks that we are going to get
potentially another increase in July and
then the cut in September a cut in
November and a cut in December as the
FED starts to ease up on those financial
conditions again remember Financial
conditions were eased by the FED pumping
money out into the economy into the
banks even though they didn't engage in
any quantitative easing or cut rates
when they when the FED pushes money into
the banking system that eases Financial
conditions makes it easier for banks to
lend one of those small businesses to
make more to do more borrowing and to
get the economy flowing now they are
reversing all that as we saw with their
fed with the FED balance sheet chart I
put up here on screen a little earlier
all of the things the FED has done to
ease Financial conditions are starting
to come off and that likely is going to
affect markets soon and certainly is
going to affect the real economy
and so this today's press conference
today's statement I think really just
said in motion all right we are
resetting where things are and now we're
moving into this new phase of the
economy of the job market and all that
good stuff but again it will be all
about the data the FED says they are
data dependent believe them because if
the data comes in surprisingly if the
data comes in above expectations below
expectations you can expect the FED to
react and you can expect markets to
react to that that takes us to our next
Point really well which is what comes
next well tomorrow we get the Challenger
job Cuts report that comes out early in
the morning you're going to check that
out that's from private agency
Challenger Grand Christmas they track
the number of layoffs AKA job cut
announcements AKA job cuts that is
picked up pretty significantly as we
we've started moved into this year we
have seen 400 increase in March from
last year where job Cuts were and we'll
see if layoffs continue to pick up steam
that's not great news for the economy
when then on Friday we get the jobs
report we will be right here for Market
takes breaking down what we've seen and
what and what to make of that job report
Fed chair Jerome Powell pointed out
during his press conference today
there's been an average of 345 000 jobs
added over the first three months the
first quarter this year that is a very
high Pace a very fast pace and the FED
wants to slow that down they want fewer
people getting jobs they want fewer
raises they want less wage growth among
economy among the folks in the economy I
know that sounds strange but that's what
they want because they need to slow
inflation down so jobs Friday is going
to be big we hope you'll be with us
right here on Market takes then next
week we've got our look ahead on Monday
again Market takes baby don't miss it
and on Wednesday the other Big Kahuna
coming out will be CPI the Consumer
Price Index that report is going to tell
us what's going on with inflation and
all eyes will be on that as the FED
moves back towards its data dependent
stance no more we we can't just say okay
the fed's going to raise this month
because you know that's what they've
been doing that's all over we're moving
into a new regime where a report like
CPI the jobs report PPI any number of
reports the economic cost index could
move the FED to raise cut hold Pat and
you're going to want to watch that data
because that's going to be big that's
what the FED is depending on moving
forward anyway that's going to wrap it
up for us here on Market takes I'm your
host Dion rabone I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me I hope you'll do it again
on Friday when we come back right here
for another edition of Market takes